started drinking at a very early age as
soon as you get me and zonic you know
was a young kid you know I had possible
something I could never drink again
without cirrhosis and I've got me lost
rage read a couple attempts now for me
the heartbreaking thing was though when
I wanted to start an occult what we
brain with remembrance there's all the
times that a dad made me feel good at
the heart of a lot of addiction of
relapses memories linking using the
environment to control my urge to use
drugs that's it if that is at the crux
of it you know that there is a spark
inside their head that when you're not
feeling so happy that tells you that a
drink and or a drug will change that if
we can get these associative memories
around alcohol to destabilize you can
fundamentally alter the way it exists or
you can stop it
persisting potentially in its entirety
memory tells us how to behave in certain
situations it tells us how we can find
rewards and how we can avoid getting
punishments drugs tap into that system
particularly strongly by being highly
rewarding so we're very ready to learn
about things that predicts drugs and how
we can get them in certain circumstances
that can lead to these memories kind of
overtaking behavior and driving towards
continued drug use with a extremely
motivated behavioral response and that's
what we see in addiction I can't
remember the first time I got drunk and
I just remember that whenever there was
alcohol about I would always drink it
because I loved the way it made me feel
and I'd sometimes as a little lad drink
things that would make me sick
and that didn't seem to matter I would
do anything that made me feel feel
different and in the end you know and me
organs just decided to stop where and I
collapsed people tend to start using
alcohol obviously it's a legal drug in a
social setting people might use it for
other different reasons including you
know if they've got other emotional or
social problems there as a kind of self
medication and all of these things
determine how rewarding people find
alcohol so if it's used socially then
it's going to be a big social reward
you're happy when you're using it if
you're using it to reduce the kind of
negative emotions that you experience
due to something else maybe depression
then it's also going to have a kind of
rewarding value by alleviating those
feelings and so you're learning this
really high reward value of alcohol and
then despite people's best efforts
because they are always surrounded by
these reminders of drinking there's no
way for them to really break out of that
cycle those feelings are being triggered
by these memory associations that are
learned during drug use so if we can
weaken those then we get people a
fighting chance after they've managed to
become abstinent to stay abstinent in
the long term so that those kind of
finishes memories don't keep research
and causing relapse so a good way to
think about memories in terms of how
they're formed and updated and changed
is like a bunch of Lego bricks so if you
had a load of Lego bricks which are kind
of the kind of like the neurons in your
ring by sticking them together in
certain configurations you can you can
build anything you can build any shape
you want you can create any memory that
the world might throw at you if you've
built something and you realize that
it's not quite right to bricks out of
place somewhere you need to break down
that structure and rebuild it to make it
in the new form that's correct and the
brains doing that all the time because
the world is changing around us it's
updating our memories to keep them
relevant to keep make sure they're
predicting the right things so if you
get in there between that point where
they're unstable and between when they
reach stabilize they're updated form and
interfere with a drug or with some new
learning you can either stop them being
rebuilt and so they're they'll just be
kind of a pile of LEGO bricks a weakened
memory or you can reconfigure them in a
new way so it would be a completely
different structure altogether my
interest is in addiction and new
treatments for addiction but there's
very few studies that exist currently
looking at doing this kind of treatment
in humans but that learning process this
idea of maladaptive learning can be
extended to lots of other psychiatric
disorders research on anxiety disorders
both in humans and in animals can be
used and translated to develop
interventions for people with addiction
some of my phobia once
being so afraid of spider that if you
see a spider you can flip to any field
addiction suppose it's the need to have
something more than anything else even
if you try to think about it in a
different way you can't put no variety
you know I didn't have I didn't have
enough power to do that
even if you know that it is silly what
you're doing cannot be silenced me self
writes I'm not gonna drink oh you use
again you can stop thinking about it in
that way because that's just how you see
it and how you feel about it and you
really believe that spider is going to
I've been afraid of spiders well as long
as I can remember all my life so I saw
this this research and then I read if
you were afraid of spiders you could
participate she was like the fourth or
fifth participants was Sasha from the
treatment I expected not very much
because I didn't know a lot about it and
I hoped it would work but I wasn't sure
it would she was so terrified she
started to cry no just stare at this
Farley oh [ __ ] but we do in memory
reconsolidation intervention is we
target to fear memory itself and try to
weaken or even erase the memory my name
is a Lisa and I'm here to try to fix my
spider phobia I guess you can call it
answer this room huh okay so then I'm
going to ask you some questions about
your respirator for your spider phobia
the day of my treatment I got there and
I had to fill in a lot of questions
about my phobia first and then they also
need to go to the other room where the
spider was he was in a cage and the door
was open I immediately saw that door was
open and they asked me to get close to a
line on the ground or to at least get
close to the line and if I could go for
her an education I couldn't even get
close to the line what could happen yeah
I know nothing will probably happen when
I'm just scared yeah
first I asked him to touch the tarantula
I asked them how much they fear they
experienced how much distress they
experienced up to a maximum of fear
memory reactivation when they are really
in an mode of approaching the tarantula
they in fact do not touch the tarantula
I stopped I closed the tank and we walk
to the other room upon memory retrieval
or memory reactivation is in fact offers
in a window of opportunity to interfere
with the memory itself and we give our
participants a drug propanolol which
interferes with the protein synthesis
necessary to restabilized the memory
trace
I took the film
and then I go that was the first day and
then we normally ask them to come back
one week later in our previous study
also three months later and one year
later and we do behavior tests with
spiders to see whether the fear behavior
has been changed
I've been dreaming of spiders last night
they can walk through the yellow line
yeah I open the tank they're years again
when I got in there I they asked me to
get close to the gauge and I feel like I
can do that never sleep
wait a minute yeah I can do that huh
okay and I got close to the cage and I
was looking at that spider and not
afraid at all and I just knew in my head
like but I'm really really afraid of
this spider and I'm terrified of this
fight I'm I'm afraid that he can jump
out of the cage and and I didn't feel
that I didn't feel any fear at all and
they asked can you touch it and I'm like
yeah she touched it she asked me and I
just parted on my hand and I could not
believe it
although I was a bear of course of all
the animal literature of our own studies
on fear conditioning I see many many
times the effect in the lab but I still
could not believe that it was possible
to change such a strong fear behavior
and in in fact a very brief intervention
how do you feel in terms of distress of
fairness kill from zero to hundred I'm a
little bit nervous yes
no I'm actually touching one I was kind
of preparing myself to do I wanted to do
it but I'm not sure if I really expected
it because yesterday I was more scared
and I thought I would be yesterday I
thought I would be able to just grab it
and I would be fine but I was not that
brave yesterday but today I feel okay
can we get it out huh actually feel
completely relaxed it kind of intrigued
when I look back on it I'm really happy
how it went because it
it's really a change in my life and the
expectation was lower than what it's
yeah how it turned out to be one of the
main things with addiction is the
strength of the memories that we're
dealing with they're going to be just
maybe orders of magnitude stronger than
the learning that's gone on in in a
phobia and that's that's why we're doing
a lot of the research that we're doing
it's not actually that easy to disable
eyes a memory that's as well and as the
ones that that exist in in alcoholism or
any other drug addiction because they
learned over thousands or tens of
thousands of episodes but the similarity
between addiction and anxiety disorders
means that we can learn from animal work
on addiction and also the other way
around
this still kind of early days for this
treatment we're doing some of the first
studies looking at it in humans I think
it shows really great promise out of
everything we've had so far and that's
come out of kind of four basic
neuroscience and pharmacology of
addiction this is the first way that we
really found that we could potentially
permanently modify these problematic
memories I don't know and silica until I
came out with there's a treatment that
would instantly solve that craving but
I'm sure it will be a massive help to
most every people once doctrine can I
use it
with phobias and addiction it's got a
big influence on your life it's
something you experience daily because
with spiders you see spiders daily they
are everywhere and also with addiction I
can imagine that it's in your head every
day and you're busy with it every day so
if something changes something that's in
every day you live then of course your
life's really different
you